your idol Gordie Howe passed away this
year and just a huge legend in the game
you your careers overlapped as pros for
a brief brief period of time even though
he's a complete other generation you got
to play with Gordie Howe what was that
like you know we all get an opportunity
or sometimes you get an opportunity to
meet your idols and sometimes you walk
away and go I was okay or that was just
alright and I met Gordie Howe when I was
10 and my dad said how was it and I said
you know he was bigger and nicer and
better than I had in my ten-year-old
brain and he was just a real special man
and he was the greatest hockey player
ever lived and he happened to be the
nicest man we went to his funeral it was
the most surreal thing I'd ever seen
9:00 in the morning till 9:00 p.m. at
night people lined up and came in and
went by his casket for 12 straight hours
and it was people from Russia and France
and England and of course North America
so he was just something someone that
was very very special when you started
to play I think you were 17 and you got
on the ice with Gordie now you had met
him when you were 10 no 17 and they're a
player playing you're actually playing
against him that must have been surreal
I was in the warm-up I was so excited to
play against Gordie Howe and I thought
wow this is something really cool and
we're skating around in the warm-up
getting ready for the game and every
time I went by Gordie he was winking at
me and I this is really cool he's
getting me excited about the game and I
got back in the locker room and I said
to one of the guys I said Courtney house
out there winking to me goes no no no
he's got a blinking problem shift I
stole the puck from him when I was going
the other way and all of a sudden I felt
this stick and he cracked me over the
thumb kind of cracked my thumb and he
said kid don't ever take the puck from
me again I said no I never will you just
had to teach the new
you